[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 ساعه
الايقاع السريع والمختلف والمعلومه
المباشره الوافيه وفيها الكثير البدايه من
العناوين
استراتيجيه اوكرانيه جديده بدلا من الهجوم
المضاد الجواسيس وسيله والعنق الروسي هدف
انتصر اردوغان لكن في انتظاره ما هو اصعب
التضخم وازمات الاقتصاد هل يستطيع وقف
النزيف
وايضا في ملفات الساعه 60
بشبح ذكريات قديمه مرعبه دارفور امام خطر
حرب اهليه جديده
اسبوع من التوترات بين بكين وواشنطن ينتهي
باتفاق امريكي
يفاقم التوتر
[موسيقى]
الحرب في اوكرانيا بالنسبه للكثيرين في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو شيء يحدث بعيدا جدا
يرونه فقط على الشاشات حتى بدات الهجمات
الاوكرانيه في العمق الروسي هجمات اخرى
اخرجت بوتين ليتهم بمحاوله ترويع
المواطنين الروس هو تغيرا في الحرب التي
تشهد تغيرات كل فتره لكن من ثوابتها
الاجهزه السريه التابعه او موسكو تخوض
معارك معلومات واستخبارات اثارها انعكست
على الميدان تاريخ مشترك جمع جهاز
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ونظيره الروسي لكن
وبعد تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي اختار كل
منهما طريقا منف
بعد ان بات الجهاز الاوكراني هيكلا
صوفيتيا بخصائص غربيه
[موسيقى]
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه على عكس نظيرتها
الروسيه تحولت الى جهاز صغير متحرر وعلى
عكس سلسله الاسلوب السوفيتي الذي عانى
كثيرا من البيروقراطيه زيلينسكي
عينو رئيسا للجهاز الامني عام 2020
بودانوب شاب لم يتدرج في الجيش لكنه يمتلك
تجربه طويله
فيلينسكي منح بودانوب ورقه بيضاء من اجل
نقل الحرب داخل روسيا بكل الوسائل والهدف
اجعل الروس يشعرون بالحرب مهمه بودنوب
الاولى كانت تطهير الادارات الاوكرانيه من
عملاء روسيا مهمه شاقه بالطبع لكنها نجحت
لاعتمادها على معلومات غربيه في اعتقال
800 عميل روسي منذ بدايه الحرب فيكتور ميد
بيتشوك واحد من الثمان مئه من اهم رجال
روسيا
في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
صفقه تبادل
شوك عفوا مع روسيا مقابله 200 جندي شكلت
اسسا دعائيه لصالح رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه بودانوب لكن رغم ذلك هناك
ازمات يعانيها الجهاز 60 عميلا
للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه انشقوا واختاروا
البقاء والتعاون مع موسكو في المناطق التي
سيطرت عليها ربما لانهم كانوا منذ البدايه
عملاء لروسيا احتمال اخر هو ان روسيا
اقنعتهم بالانضمام اليها ليتحصلوا بعدها
على مناصب جيده في الادارات الجديده
مسؤولون كبار في الاداره يشتبه في علاقتهم
مع روسيا سهلوا عمليه دخول الجيش الروسي
لخرسون وايضا الى مقاطعه في بدايه الحرب
الا ان الاخطر هم من ينتمون للاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه
اعتقلت كياب ضابط استخبارات سابقيه يبلغ
من العمر 77 عاما بعد تقديمه لمقر اقامه
الجيش الاوكراني في البيب معلوماته تسببت
في تلقي كياب اكبر ضربه في غرب البلاد
[موسيقى]
كل الجهود الروسيه لم تمنع نجاحات بودانوف
نقل الفوضى الى روسيا وتحقيق هدف زيلنسكي
الروس الان يتدمرون من الحرب والبدايه
كانت باستهداف صحفيين ومؤثرين داخل روسيا
بعض العمليات التي شهدتها روسيا نعم لقد
قام جهازنا باستهداف بعض الاعلاميين
والمؤثرين داخل روسيا لن اذكر الاسماء لكن
لدينا قائمه للشخصيات المستهدفه وفي كل
هذا النشاط الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
ونجاحها جعل الاصوات في روسيا تتعالى من
اجل تصفيه قادتها وهنا بالطبع بودانوف هو
الهدف الاول والاوحد
بعد سلسله الاعمال التخريبيه في روسيا
وعمليات الاغتيال التي استهدفت صحفيين
موالين للسلطه مثل دار يدوجنا وفلادلين
والتي تقف خلفها الاستخبارات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه كما تقول موسكو من اجل بث
الزعر والخوف بين السكان رئيس الاستخبارات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه كيرين بودانوف يصبح
الان في روسيا هدفا مشروعا للاستخبارات
الخاصه الروسيه ولقوات الصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه ولاي شخص كان دعوات تناقلتها
صحف وبعد وسائل الاعلام الروسيه الى
الدوله من اجل ان تظهر القوه من خلال بعض
الاعمال الجاده التي من شانها ان تعقد
حياه الهيكل العسكري للعدو وليس فقط من
خلال التمركز على طول خط التماس
لماذا هم احياء بودانوف على قيد الحياه
لماذا وزير الدفاع الاوكراني رجليكوف على
قيد الحياه لماذا هؤلاء الارهابيون احياء
دانيلف الى حد الان على قيد الحياه لم
نوجه الى حد الان ضربه مباشره لمراكز
القياده النازيه انهم بشكل مباشر يستهدفون
الشرطه وقاده المناطق الذين عينتهم روسيا
وبالرغم من اعترافهم بالوقوف وراء التفجير
جسر القرم واستهداف بيل جورد
لكن كيف نجحت اوكرانيا في تنفيذ عمليات
داخل روسيا اوكرانيا بقيت جزءا من روسيا
لمده خمسه قرون فتره كافيه لامتزاج السكان
الذين تجمعهم الكثير من الامور المشتركه
من الدين واللغه والتقاليد يعيش الان ما
بين اربعه الى خمسه ملايين روسيا من اصل
اوكراني في روسيا هم متغلغلون في الاداره
الروسيه والجيش ايضا وكثير منهم مستعد
لخدمه كياب وبطرق غير متوقعه احيانا مثلا
مع بدايه الحرب تفاجا الروس بالصحفيه
مارينا او سيني كوبا وهي ترفع لافته
مناهضه للحرب اتضح لاحقا ان اصلها اوكراني
ولدت هناك لتنطلق مشكله روسيا مع مزدوجي
الجنسيه ومنذ اندلع الحرب اكثر من مليون
لاجئ اوكراني دخلوا روسيا الكثير من
العمليات التخريبيه يقف ورائها النازحون
من اوكرانيا ولذلك يدرس البرلمان الرو سي
حاليا اصدار قانون يحد من حركتهم داخل
البلاد فئه اخرى مواطنون روس معارضون
للحرب او تم شرائهم من قبل الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه اغلبهم من المتقاعدين او
المراهقين او الائمه العملاء المدربين فقد
كلفوا بتنفيذ العمليات الاهم
[موسيقى]
اخر على النجاح هو ما يحدث اخيرا في
بلغرود الهجمات الاوكرانيه على بالقرود
بدات مباشره بعد سقوط بخموت ولم تتوقف
طيله الاسبوع الاخير من شهر مايو استهدفت
والاستهدافات فقد شملت كل المناطق التي
تقع في مرمى المدفعيه الاوكرانيه وهي
مناطق حدوديه تقع جنوب بلغرود ويبلغ تعداد
سكانها نصف مليون نسمه في الثلاثين من
مايو استهدفت اوكرانيا موسكو من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بثمان مسيرات ولكن وبسبب
طيرانها المنخفض
خمسا منها بانظمه الدفاع الجيش الروسي
استخدم ايضا انظمه التشويش الالكتروني
بسبب طيران الثلاث منها وسط البنايات وهذا
الهجوم لم يخلف اصابات لكنه بالطبع حمل
دلالات رمزيه
[موسيقى]
كل هذه النجاحات تحولت لتحديات امام روسيا
رغم انها اعدت العده قبل ذلك وبسنوات عام
2008 ورغم نجاح العمليه الروسيه في جورجيا
عمليا وجهت انتقادات كبيره لجهاز
الاستخبارات بوتا اعتبرها فرصه لفرض
الاصلاح وعين ايجور كوب مديرا للاستخبارات
العسكريه ولا يزال محتفظا بمنصبه حتى
الانبا اسس شبكه عملاء متعدده في اوكرانيا
وبدلا بدا الاستعداد للحرب الحرب الحاليه
صيفه عام 2021 الا انه طلب من بوتين تاجيل
العمليه من اجل ضمان نجاحها
وتنرفض التاجيل ووافق على ذلك كان يعدل
تقاريره بما يرضي سيد الكرملين وربما يكون
ذلك سبب احتفاضه بمصيبه حتى الان لكن بعض
التقارير الخاطئه حول استقبال الروس
بالورود وهروب القياده الاوكرانيه كان لها
وقع كارثي وذلك اضافه لتدمير اوكرانيا
بمساعده الغرب لشبكه العملاء في اوكرانيا
ضربه قويه لكن روسيا لم تقل كلمتها
الاخيره معلومات الناتو كانت مكشوفه
لروسيا ايضا منذ البدايه
[موسيقى]
من مدينه عرس دنماركيه ينضم الينا سامر
الياس صحفيه متخصص في اشياءنا الروسي اهلا
بك يعني في هذه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه في التجسس تحديدا وحرب
الجواسيس يتصدر اسم بودانوف المشهد بشكل
كبير وجاءت ايضا تصريحات الرئيس بوتين اول
امس لتؤكد ان الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه حققت
نوعا ما اهدافها في يعني يخاف في تخويف
الروس يعني هذا الوهج لبودانوفيل الان هل
هو بروباندا غربيه في الاعلام الغربي ام
انه بالفعل يعني الرجل حقق اهدافه داخل
روسيا
تحيه طيبه لا اعتقد بدايه بان هذا غربيه
من اجل الترويج لبودانوف وايضا
النجاح في ترويع الروس وهذه العمليات في
العمق الروسي لم تكن هي بدايه هذه
النجاحات تحدثت مع نجاحات كثيره لكن ربما
يكون النجاح الاول والاهم
ومقابله الفشل الاكبر بالنسبه لروسيا هو
النجاح بمعرفه موعد الهجوم ومعرفه الخطط
الروسيه بالهجوم على مطار جستومي القربه
حين كان هناك احد رجال الاعمال المقربين
من
تقليبه اليهم ولكن في المقابل كان عميلا
لجهاز المخابرات واعلم
فيبدا على مطار قسيمه ما ادى الى تعطيل
الخطه الروسيه التي كانت تنطلق اساسا من
السيطره على مدينه كييف وقلب نظام الحكم
واخراج جيلينسكي من هناك هناك نجاحات
متتاليه وهو ايضا الفشل الاساسي بالنسبه
لجهاز المخابرات الروسيه نظرا لانه كان
مخترق كما اتضح لاحقا والعامل الثاني بانه
لم يتم استقبال جنود الروس بالورود في
كافه مناطق اوكرانيا في الشرق الاوكراني
خاصه حيث يوجد غالبيه من المواطنين من ذوي
الاثنيه الروسيه وهم مواطنون اوكرانيون
منذ عام 1991 يعني ايضا سيد سامر هذه
القوات الاستخباراتيه والنظام الاستخبارات
الجهاز الاستخباراتي الاوكراني ما كان
ليصل الى هذا ايضا التفوق لولا الدعم
الغربي الاستخباراتي من السي اي اي تحديدا
والاستخبارات البريطانيه كذلك وبحسب
تحاول الان كبح جماح بودنوب لتفادي اي
هجمات على الداخل الروسي هل برايك الغرب
فقد السيطره على هذا الجهاز الذي طوره
بنفسه
اعتقد بان الغرب الان في معضله حقيقيه كما
هي روسيا في معضله المعضله لدى الجانب
الغربي بانه لا يريد ان تتطور الاحداث الى
مواجهه مباشره بين روسيا والناتو لكن في
المقابل يريدون اطاله امد الحرب باقصى
درجه ممكنه واستنزاف القوه الروسيه عسكريا
سياسيا اقتصاديا اخلاقيا امام العالم
لاضعاف روسيا في العالم عقابا لبدء الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا في 24 فبراير من العام
2022 واعتقد بان جانب الامريكي
والبريطاني بشكل عام كان فرحا لهذه الحرب
لانه استطاع تنفيذ عدد كبير من المخططات
ودعم ابو دانه بطبيعه الحال الجانب الغربي
لا يريد مواجهه مع روسيا يريد ايضا ان
تبقى اوكرانيا تحت جناحيه ان صح القول
ولكن
هي تستطيع ايقاف هذا الموضوع والسيطره
عليه فلنتذكر على سبيل المثال بان شبكات
الانترنت الموجوده في اوكرانيا وسائل
الغربيه ستارلينج وايلون ماسك الاداره
الامريكيه بالامس اعلنت بانها سوف تقوم
بدعم له ماسك او دفع مبالغ له مقابل
استخدام ستار لينك في اوكرانيا ومن دونها
لم يكن لتحقق اوكرانيا اي نجاحات في موضوع
الانترنت ايضا
وايضا الاستخبارات البريطانيه والامريكيه
تقدم معلومات كبيره للجانب الاوكراني لكن
هناك عامل ربما ساهم في الشهرين الاخيرين
بفقدان ثقه بعد تسريب الوثائق من
المخابرات الامريكيه من من عضو في
المخابرات الامريكيه وهي الفضيحه المعروفه
ربما باتت اوكرانيا تتحفظ اكثر على خطتها
ولا تريد مشاركتها
مع الغرب نعم اوضحت الفكره شكرا لك كنت
معنا من دنماركيه سامر الياس صحفي متخصص
في الشان الروسي
لاعب حر في النيتو يبحث عن مصالحه حتى وين
تعارضت مع حليفته واشنطن في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ولايه تتجدد في قرن جديد
التغيير الذي انتظرته شريحه كبيره في
تركيا لم يحدث فازار الاتراك لم يقتنعوا
بمشروع المعارضه التي نجحت لاول مره في
الطريق في التاريخ في الوصول لدور ثاني
للفوضى التي اعقبت الزلزال ولا مشكلات
الاقتصاد اثرت في شعبيه اردوغان في مناطق
الاناضول العميقه اعلانوا النصر رافقته
احتفالات عارمه لكنها لم تدم طويلا فتح
فصل التحديات القائمه والجديده ومهمه
اردوغان لن تكون سهله
لم يخسر احد اليوم 85 مليون فائز نقدر
المسؤوليه الممنوحه لنا من قبل امتنا لا
نشعر بالاهانه او الاستياء او الغضب من اي
شخص لقد حان الوقت الان لوضع كل الخلافات
والصراعات التي شهدتها فتره الانتخابات
ونتحد حول اهدافنا واحلامنا الوطنيه
كثيره ستشهدها تركيا والبدايه من اقوى
تحالفا للمعارضه معارضه شهدته تركيا
الحديثه الطويله السداسيه وهي التي تضم
احزابا من طيارات مختلفه لم يجمعها الا
مشروع الاطاحه باردوغان لكن الخساره كانت
مزدوجه كرسي الرئاسه والانتخابات
البرلمانيه وبما ان الانتخابات المحليه لم
يعد يفصلها سوى ثمانيه اشهر ارتفعت اصوات
التغيير داخل الاحزاب المعارضه
وزير الدوله السابق محمد سيفيجان الذي شكك
فيه فعاليه الداعمين الخمسه
باطلاق النار عليه من الخلف وذلك بسبب عدم
خروجهم للولايات لحشد الناخبين مطالب
التغيير وصلت
لحزبدار اوغلو حزب الشعب الجمهوري طلبات
تانجو اوزجان باستقاله كلش دار اوغلو بعد
ان خسر امام اردوغان ووصفه بالطاعون الذي
سياكل رقبه كل من يدعمه في الاستمرار
ميرال اكشنر زعيمه الحزب الجيد حازت
المرتبه الخامسه في البرلمان وبعد ان وعدت
مؤيديها بالانتصار وهو ما جعل رئيس لجنه
الانضباط في حزبها يدعوها الى الاستقاله
الفوريه
[موسيقى]
ضرب اردوغانو عصفورين بحجر واحد نال
الرئاسه والبرلمان من جهه وادخل المعارضه
في دوامه من الفوضى من جهه اخرى الا ان
الاقتصاد تركي سيكون اكبر تحديات الرئيس
وهو الذي وضعه على راسي اولوياته في وعوده
الانتخابيه
يعني الفائزه مع خفض اسعار الفائده سينخفض
التضخم مشكله التضخم ليست اسعار البطاطا
او الطماطم او الباذنجان او المواد الاخرى
القضيه الرئيسيه هي اسعار الفائده التغيير
الرئيسي سياتي من هناك
اوله والتحديات التضخم بلغ بحسب الارقام
الرسميه اربعه واربعين في المئه بينما
اكدت معاهد مستقله ان الرقم اعلى بكثير
اكثر من الضعف مئه وخمسه في المئه ارقام
شهدت هذا ثلاث دول في التاريخ الارجنتين
زيمبابوي وفنزويلا وبينما تعالج كل الدول
ازمه التضخم برفع اسعار الفائده لاردوغان
وسلوب اخر خفض اسعار الفائده الى 8.5
الشهر الماضي من 19% عام 2019 خطوه وصفها
الخبراء بصب الزيت على النار لكن هل تسعى
انقره وراء خفض قيمه الليره كلما انخفض
سعر الليره كلما كانت اسعار المنتجات
التركيه اقل في الاسواق العالميه وهو ما
يرفع من قيمه الصادرات لكن ومع اقتراب
الانتخابات زادت اهميه القدره الشرائيه
للاطراك اردوغان رفع الرواتب بنسبه 50%
وهو اخر للتضخم كذلك مليارات الدولارات من
اجل الحفاظ على اسعار صرف الليره قبل
الانتخابات وهنا جاء الدور على استنزاف
احتياطي الصرف وهنا تحدي اخر
تركيا مؤشرات اقتصاديه متضاربه بعد اعلان
نتائج الانتخابات وفوز اردوغان بولايه
الرئاسيه جديده
فرغم ارتفاع مؤشرات بورصه اسطنبول بنسبه
قاربت اربعه في المئه انخفضت الليره
التركيه مقابل الدولار الى
20.18 حيث يتوقع محلل بنك مورجان ستانلي
ان الليره سوف تنخفض الى 28 مقابل الدولار
الواحد في نهايه العام
ويعزو محللون هذا التراجع الى ضخ البنك
المركزي الاموال قبل الانتخابات للحفاظ
على سعر الصرف في مقابل هذه الانباء ذكرت
مصادر مقربه من الرئيس التركي انه يريد من
وزير الماليه الاسبق والاقتصادي المرموق
محمد شمشك تولي الملف الاقتصادي لكن
جيمشيك يريد حريه اتخاذ القرارات دون تدخل
من احد ويبدو ان الجانبين اتفقا على معظم
النقاط وان شمشك سيكون ضمن التشكيله
الوزاريه الجديده
لا شك ان المشهد الانتخابيه التركيه كان
محطه انظارا عالميه مشاركه بلغت تسعه
وثمانين في المئه لبلد يناهز عدد سكانه
التسعين مليونا مشهد لم تتوقعه ربما
العواصم الغربيه او خيبت النتائج امالها
رغم ذلك من المانيا الى امريكا مرورا
بفرنسا وعلى غير العاده لم تتاخر هذه
المره تهنئه الزعماء لاردوغان مؤخرا
السياسه الاوروبيه مع عده دول تختلف معها
في التوجهات مثل المجار والهند والبرازيل
باتت مختلفه توقفت اوروبا عن الانتقادات
وعملت على المصلحه المشتركه
او الغربيه مع هذه الدول تهدف لمنع المد
الروسي وتقسيم العالم الجديد الى معسكر
شرقي وغربي تركيا ايضا تندرج ضمن هذه
الفئه بالنسبه للغرب فهي مثلا تلعب دور
الوسيط مع روسيا بشان السلام مع اوكرانيا
وبشان اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب لكن هناك في
الدول الغربيه من يغرد خارج الصربه
[موسيقى]
بمجرد مغادره بريطانيا للاتحاد الاوروبي
تحولت الى لاعب حر داخل الناتو يبحث عن
مصالحه حتى وان تعارضت مع حليفته
التاريخيه واشنطن اقصاء امريكا لتركيا من
برنامج مقاتله الجيل الخامس
400 الروسي ضربه موجعه لانقره التي تسعى
لتعويض مقاتلات اف 16 المتقادمه الا ان
مساعده من لندن طلبت الازمه الى مشروع
قومي تركيا اعلنت نيتها تطوير مقاتله تي
اف اكس من الجيل الخامس والتصميم وصف بانه
نسخه من افخم 35 لكن ماذا عن المعدات شركه
البريطانيه التي صممت مقاتله تايبون
الاوروبيه قررت التكفل بالتصميم ومرافقه
المشروع التركي في صفقه قدرت بمئه وخمسه
وعشرين مليون دولار وفي الوقت نفسه شركه
رولز رويس البريطانيه الرائده في صناعه
محركات الطائرات تعلن انها مستعده لتصنيع
ونقل تكنولوجيا محركات المقاتله التركيه
مقاتله تي اف اكس لن تطير قبل عام 2030
لكنها ربحت وقتا طويلا خاصه وان المصنع
الذي كان موجها لصناعه هيكل اف 35
سيتحول لصناعه هيكل المقاتله التركيه
[موسيقى]
من اسطنبول لينضم الينا استاذ العلوم
السياسيه الدكتور سمير صالحه اهلا بك
دكتور اذا التحديات كثيره امام اردوغان في
ولايته الثالثه ولكن سنبدا من حيث تحدث هو
تحدث عن الوحده وقال ان الوقت قد حان
للوحده الان وذلك في خطاب النصر بعد
الانتخابات كيف
سيوحد الرئيس التركي الاتراك في ظل تصويت
اكثر من 25 مليون شخص ضده في هذه
الانتخابات وايضا اليوم في الجلسه
الافتتاحيه للبرلمان هناك يعني قاده من
الاحزاب احزاب المعارضه لم يحضروا
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا صحيح نعم
رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وحسب العداله
والتنميه فاز في انتخابات البرلمانيه
وبالرئاسه لكن اتفق معك هناك اكثر من تحدي
باكثر من اتجاه ينتظر رئيس اردوغان وحسبه
الان في المرحله
الانتقاليه الدستوريه
اتمام هذه المرحله يتطلب اداء اليمين
الدستوريه بالنسبه للرئيس يوم الغد تعيين
تشكيل الحكومه الجديده التي ستقود المرحله
المقبله وهي النقطه الان التي نركز عليها
كيف سيكون شكل الحكومه ستكون الحكومه مئه
بالمئه مختاره من قبل
حزب العداله والتنميه امنوا الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان سيضيف هذه المره اسماء ومقاعد
ومناصب وزاريه جديده لحلفائه سواء كان من
حزب الحركه
القوميه او غيره هذه براي نقطه اساسيه بعد
ذلك تاتي مساله يعني الدائره الاولى
المحيطه برئيس رجب طيب اردوغان هل ستكون
في مناصب وزاريه حساسه كما تعرفين هناك
ابراهيم قلن هناك كان فدان هناك عمر شريك
كل هذه الشخصيات الان تنتظر مناصب وزاريه
كما يقال في الداخل التركي لكن كما اشرت
انت ايضا مره اخرى موضوع الاستحقاقات
الكثيره يتقدمها ملف الاقتصاد نعم بالدرجه
الاولى التضخم الغلاء حمايه سعر صرف
الليره امام الدولار
وموضوع يعني تراجع السيوله نقص النقد
الاجنبي واحتياطات الذهب يعني كل هذه
العوامل تؤثر على انقاذ الاقتصاد التركي
وهو يتعلق بشكل مباشر بمخط ط اردوغان
وبرنامج اردوغان لولايته الثالثه اتحدث عن
مئويه تركيا هذا يتطلب الكثير على الصعيد
العسكري والاقتصادي وايضا الاجتماعي
ويحتاج الى المال لتنفيذ البرنامج يعني
فكيف على ماذا يعول اردوغان
لتحسين الوضع الاقتصادي في ظل هذه الظروف
اظن التركيز هو على مراجعه السياسات
الاقتصاديه والماليه
المعتمده في الاعوام الاخيره تحديدا في
العوامل الثلاثه الاخيره وما الان يقال
حول
تكليف وزير الماليه الاقتصاد الاسباب محمد
بتولي ملف الاقتصاد مهم جدا كيف ستكون
العلاقه بين الوزير المفترض
والرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان هذه مساله ايضا
في غايه الاهميه وتحتاج الى متابعه لماذا
لانه الوزير عندما غادر الوزاره في العام
2019 كان في تباعد اساسي في تقديرات في
المواقف في السياسات بينه وبينما يقوله
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الان كيف سيكون
ستكون التفاهمات هل سيعطي رئيس اردوغان
الوزير شيم شيك صلاحيات واسعه باتجاه
تشكيل فريق العمل الذي يريده هو تبني
سياسه اقتصاديه ماليه في اكثر من علامه
استفهام كما تعرفين الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان ترحم معادلات تخفيض
نسب التضخم والغلاء مرتبط بتخفيض سعر
الفائده البنكيه المصرفيه
عنده معادله مغايره لذلك هو يتبنى
السياسات الكلاسيكيه التقليديه
ايضا الى جانب هذه العوامل الداخليه لن
نقفل ايضا الجانب الخارجي وانه نظريا يعد
يعني مهم جدا
للاقتصاد في الداخل التركي العلاقات
الخارجيه تحسن الاقتصاد التركي ويبدو ان
هناك يعني قبول من الجانب الغربي هذه
المره بولايه اردوغان ظاهريا هناك دعوه من
المانيا لاردوغان ايضا هناك تهنئه من
الزعماء الغربيين يعني بفوزه في هذه
الانتخابات ولكن ايضا هذا يت طلب تغيير
السياسه الخارجيه لاردغان
السياسه الخارجيه التركيه منذ عامين
تحديدا في مسار جديد بعد
مراجعه العديد من المواقف التعامل مع
ملفات اقليميه حساسه بالنسبه لتركيا ولكن
انت اشرت الى مصطلح مهم جدا ظاهريا في
بالنسبه للغرب نعم هذه المساله حتى الان
ما زالت شكليه يعني
توجيه الرسائل التهنئه للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان لا يعني انه العلاقات التركيه
الغربيه ستذهب بمسار جديد كما اشرتم انتم
ايضا قبل قليل في اكثر من ملفات خلاف على
المستوى الثنائي مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تحديدا كيف ستتم تسويه هذه
الملفات
وانقره متمسكه بسياستها الانفتاحيه على
روسيا هذا التنسيق الاستراتيجي مع روسيا
ما زال موجود وهذه مساله تزعج الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بالمقابل هناك موضوع
عضويه السويد في حلف شمال الاطلسي الام
لحلف شمال الاطلسي سياتي الى انقره غدا
لبحث هذه المساله هل سيكون هناك تغيير في
سياسه تركيا انا رايي الشخصي من الصعب جدا
في هذه المرحله تحديدا الان تغير تركيا من
موقفها وسياساتها احيانا عضويه السويد
باختصار هناك اكثر من ملف اقليمي تركيز
بالنسبه لانقره هو على الانفتاح اكثر
فاكثر على دول الاقليم اكثر من ان يكون
على الانفتاح الغربيه
استاذ العلوم السياسيه دكتور سمير صالحه
[موسيقى]
رغم ان المعارك في السودان مركزها الخرطوم
الا ان اقليم دارفور وعنصر مؤثر في النزاع
الوضع في الاقليمي يبدو اكثر تعقيدا من
العاصمه حساسيات عرقيه وقبليه انتشارا
للحركات المسلحه المنبثقه عن حرب استمرت
16 عاما بين عامي 2003 و 2019 رسميا تحاول
الحركات المسلحه في دارفور البقاء على
الحياد سعيا لتجنب اشتعال نيران الماضي في
الاقليم ونحن لا نجيب فلان ولاده علان
لا نجيف ننشر للفلان ولا ننصر للعلان لكن
نحن دائما ما محيدين نحن ما محيدين ليه
لانه هذه التراب السودان هذا الوطن
السودان هذا الشعب السودان هذه الامراه
السودانيه نحن نحميها
لكن رغم تصريحاتي حاكم دارفور بعض الحركات
شارك الى جانب الجيش شاركت الى جانب الجيش
ضد الدعم السريع تحت لواء القوات الامنيه
في المشتركه التي تتالف من الجيش والشرطه
والحركات المسلحه الواقعه على اتفاق سلام
جوبا للتعامل مع الانفلات الامني
والنزاعات القبليه وحمايه المدنيين في
الاقليم امر اكده وزير الدفاع السوداني
ياسين ابراهيم ياسين دعم قد يفسر عدم سقوط
ولايه شمال دارفور ومركزها الفاشر تحت
سيطره قوات الدعم السريع ورغم انها مسقط
راس حمدي
قواتي الدعم السريع للسيطره على كامل
ولايات دارفور الخمسه سيدفع الحركات
المسلحه للتحرك واغلبها ستكون في صف الجيش
[موسيقى]
لكن دعونا نلقي نظره على مناطق الاشتباكات
في اقليم دارفور يتفوق الجيش نسبيا في
ولايات شمال دارفور وشرق دارفور ووسط
دارفور بينما تسيطر قوات الدعم السريعه
على جنوب دارفور في مدينه نيالا مركز
ولايه جنوب دارفور تسيطر قوات الدعم
السريع على الجزء الشرقي من المدينه بما
في ذلك مطار نياله اما قوات الجيش فتتمركز
في النصف الغربي الذي يقع به مقر الحكومه
في شمال دارفور اندلعت اشتباكات في مدن
كبكايه
وطويله والفاشر الفاشر تحديدا شهدت نشره
خمسه جمعات مسلحه مواقع على اتفاق جوبا
لمئات المقاتلين على مركبات الرباعيه
الدفع لتامين المدنيين ومقر المؤسسات
الحكوميه والمنظمات الدوليه اما الولايه
المشتعله حاليا فهي غرب دارفور الحدوديه
مع تشاد والتي كانت
المعقل الرئيسي للتمرد في عام 2003 تعرف
بتضاريسها المعقده وخاصه جبل مره مدينه
الجنينه هي نقطه النزاع المشتعله حاليا في
غرب دارفور ولا يسيطر عليها اي من الطرفين
حتى الان
وبسبب هذا الوضع المضطرب فهناك مخاوف من
سيناريو الحرب الاهليه في دارفور مره اخرى
عدد كبير من السكان يرفعون الاسلحه من اجل
حمايه اسرهم وممتلكاتهم مع غياب اعداد
كبيره من منسوبي الشرطه لدرجه ان وزير
الدفاع السوداني الفريق ياسين ابراهيم
بنفسه دعى كل القادرين على حمل السلاح
القيام بذلك والدفاع عن اسرهم
الحقيقه هو ان دارفور لم تخلو يوما من
السلاح اكثر من اربع وثمانين حركه مسلحه
مئات الالاف من قطع السلاح منتشره منذ حرب
2003 الحرب التي تسببت في انتشار الثماني
ملايين قطعه السلاح في ايدي المدنيين وفقا
لاحصائيات رسميه حينها ورغم محاولات
السيطره على الامر لم تتمكن الدوله من جمع
الا 300 الف قطعه في الفتره ما بين 2016
الى 2020
النزاع في اقليم دارفور يؤثر بالطبع على
دول الجوار حيث يتشارك الاقليم الحدود مع
اربع دول هي ليبيا تشاد جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى وجنوب السودان لا تعيشوا ايا من
الدول استقرارا امنيا فتشات تحديدا ربما
تكون ابرز المتاثرين من الصراع بسبب
التشابك القبلي والعرقي بين البلدين
فالرئيس الشديد محمد ادريس ديبي ينتمي
لقبيله الزغاوه جذورها ممتده في دارفور
ولديها تاريخ من الخلافات مع القبيله
الرزاقات العربيه والتي ينتمي لها قائد
الدعم السريع وهي احدى فروع قبائل البجاره
لذا تتخوث تشاد من سيناريو انتصار الدعم
السريع في دارفور وتحويل الاقليم عن طريق
الجنينه الى قاعده انطلاقا للمسلحين
ذوي الاصول العربيه في ليبيا وكلما طالت
المعارك في السودان
خطر تحول الجنوب الليبي الى قاعده امدادا
خلفيا بالاسلحه والغذاء والوقود المهرب من
ليبيا اما افريقيا الوسطى تحاول تجنب
التحول لصراع اقليمي حيث يشكل المثلث
الحدودي بين السودان وتشاد وجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى احد اكثر التداخل العرقي
والقبلي وتم توظيف هذا الاتصال القبلي في
الحرب الاهليه السابقه في دارفور جنوب
السودان تتخوف من عده ملفات وعلى راسها
تصدير النفط اذا تصدر جنوب السودان
انتاجها النفطي البالغ 170 الف برميل
يوميا عبر خط انابيب يخترق السودان انتهاء
بموانئ شرق السودان
صراع امريكا والصين في كل شيء حتى في
القوه الناعمه في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد العلاقه بين بكين و
واشنطن صراع نفوت سيتحول لعداء ام علاقه
تنافسيه فقط الرئيس الامريكي بايضا تحدث
عن امكانيه اذابه الجليد في العلاقات لكن
قبل ايام اعلنت تايوان او وصول اولى شحنه
صواريخ ستنجر الامريكيه راتبكين في ذلك ما
يتناقض مع تصريحات بايدن
نعارض بشده اي نوع من التعامل الرسمي بين
الولايات المتحده ومنطقه تايوان كما نرفض
اي تعاون بين الحزم الديمقراطي التقدمي
الحاكم واي قوه خارجيه
اذا الاجواء مشحونه وبحر الصين الجنوبي
الدليل الاكبر اتهامات متبادله بين
الطرفين بكينه اتهمت واشنطن لمراقبه
مناوراتها وواشنطن اتهمت مقاتله صينيه
بتنفيذ مناوره عدوانيه قرب طائره عسكريه
تابعه لها هذا التوتر زاد اكثر برفض الجيش
الصيني مجددا ترتيبا لقاء مع وزير الدفاع
الامريكي ونظيره الصيني في سنغافوره وهو
ما صفه عليه واشنطن بحسب
مصره على عدم ترتيب اللقاء طالما استمرت
العقوبات الامريكيه ضد وزير الدفاع الصيني
والتي فرضها عليه ترامب في عام 2018
وابلغت واشنطن بذلك
اعتقد ان الحادثه تظهر اهميه ابقاء خط
اتصال مفتوح بما في ذلك بين وزيري الدفاع
في البلدين من المؤسف ان الاجتماع الذي
سعى اليه الوزير استون مع نظيره الصيني لم
يتم
اجتماع اخر بجانب اجتماعي وزيرا الدفاع
البلدين كانت تحوم حوله الازمات حتى تم
اجتماع وزير التجاره والسبب كان الاتفاق
التجاري الذي وقع بالامس بين الولايات
المتحده وتايوان اعلنت منتصف مايو ان
وزيره التجاره سيتوجه لواطن وبعدها بنحو
ساعتين تم الاعلان عن اكمال المرحله
الاولى من الصفقه التجاريه اثار الامر غضب
مكان حتى تم الاجتماع الذي قال الطرفان
عنه انه كان مهما لابقاء قنوات الاتصال
مفتوحه لكن رغم ذلك الاتفاق التجاري الذي
وصفته تايوان بالتاريخي سيكون تصعيدا
للتوتر بين البلدين فهو الاكثر شمولا الذي
يوقع بين تايبي و واشنطن منذ عام
سيسهم في زياده التجاره بين البلدين من
خلال تنسيق الضوابط الجمركيه والاجراءات
التنظيميه ووضع تدابير
لمكافحه
[موسيقى]
الحرب بين البلدين في كل شيء حتى في القوه
الناعمه التي كانت احد اهم اسباب تفوق
واشنطن في الحرب البارده اليوم تنافسها
بكين تاريخيا اعتمدت القوى الناعمه
الامريكيه بشكل الرئيسي على افلامها التي
اعتبر المنتج والتر ونكر ان كل فيلم منها
بمثابه السفير امريكي لكن هوليود فقدت
بريقها امام لاعب جديد وغير متوقع العاب
الفيديو فقط في عام 2021 حقق سوق العاب
الفيديو العالمي عائدات بلغت 180 مليار
دولار طب هو على هوليود وصناعه الموسيقى
مجتمعين سوق احتكرته اليابان والولايات
المتحده لكن دخلت الصين على خط المنافسه
وبقوه انتجت سته من افضل 20 لعبه للهواتف
الجوال العام الماضي بما في ذلك من افضل
ثلاث وكما هو الحال مع تيك توك ينظر الى
الالعاب الصينيه في واشنطن على انها ادوات
لجمع البيانات الاسم وتاريخ الميلاد
وتفاصيل الدفع او مقاطع صوتيه مسجله في
عام 2020 فرضت الخزانه الامريكيه غرامه
قدرها 275 مليون دولار على شركه
جزئيا لشركه الصينيه والسبب جمع بيانات
الاطفال بشكل غير قانوني
وصلنا مشاهدينا الى نهايه موضوعاتنا
للساعه ستون وتتابعون غدا هل ينهي الوسطاء
عداوه استمرت لعقود بين مصر وايران
الميزانيه الاسرائيليه الجديده استقرار
لنتنياهو او حمل عليه
[موسيقى]
في نهايه الساعه ابرزوا احداث الساعه
بالصور من الان وحتى الساعه المقبله انا
حنين الشولي وهذه الساعه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات